hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse it's good to be back I know
it's been a while since I streamed maybe
glass Wednesday might have been the last
stream so a lot has happened since then
the first thing I like to do is just
catch you up on any all the changes in
the site and then we'll move into the
routing so just to let you know I've
currently broken a lot of stuff on the
site I have not committed the broken
stuff obviously but that's we're gonna
jump right into me being in the middle
of setting this up so I'm gonna explain
how I got to this point but just wanted
to give you all warning so since last
week
or at some point at the end of last week
I gave another presentation
about this site got great feedback from
that as well everybody who was pretty
happy not really a lot of big changes
needed to happen so the site still
pretty much looks the same if you really
want to know about any little details
that may have been updated you can
always check out the github repo try to
have descriptive commit messages when
when I can but the updates have been a
pretty pretty minimal at this point I've
been doing a lot of stuff with just
getting links to go where they're
supposed to go and I've been working
with the routing so not a lot that would
actually change the look of the site but
I like when I present to a different
group I like to try to get the links
that that group would be interested in
working otherwise I went on I did an
interview for a full-stack engineer
position
I actually made a video on just like a
recap of my interview and some advice
that I have so that's on my channel so
links in the description if you want to
check that out
it's it's available I that just went
live it took awhile to upload and
process so it actually just went live a
few minutes ago and I think I think
that's it for my for my recap I thought
there was gonna be more than that
alright so let me switch over let me
switch over to my other screen so you
all can see what's going on also for
everybody who's new here this stream is
just me going through my daily job as a
front-end developer I'm employed
full-time at a small University and
although today we're gonna be working on
some you know back-end stuff
occasionally we do occasionally we go
full stack here but primarily front end
so today the way this is gonna work is
I'm I'm gonna set a timer for 25 minutes
and we're gonna code for 25 minutes then
I'm going to take five minutes I'm gonna
look at the live chat answer any
questions that you have and we'll
probably repeat that twice then at the
end I'll answer any questions that are
left in the live chat so you have
questions go ahead and put them in there
and just kind of you know be patient
until I can get to them also this is
very interactive so if you see that I'm
doing something and you have no idea
what I'm doing
ask a question or if you have a better
idea put it in the the live chat I
frequently end up changing my plans
because someone in the live chat has
something better so feel free to to join
in and there are a lot of people in the
live chat that are more experienced than
I am so if you ask a question you may
get an answer from one of them that
that's you know pretty awesome alright
so let me set the timer I'll put it on
here on this screen so everyone can see
when we go back here someone set that 25
minute timer and I'm also going to set
this n grukk server now I did let
everyone know at the beginning so if you
didn't catch it this the site is
currently in a semi broken state because
I'm messing with some ideas that I had
for the router and that it has basically
it worked to solve the problem that I
was trying to solve but it caused a
bunch of other problems while when I did
it so now I'm at the point of like how
do I make this work in a way that
doesn't break other stuff so I'm gonna
paste a URL right now onto the live chat
and if you go to that URL you'll be able
to see the site as I'm working on it and
just in case you can't go to that you
are right now I will show you what's
going on with that I'd say here and this
is this is what we have so you'll notice
it's going to be hard to see but the URL
right now is localhost / academics / ug
/ majors and we haven't had any URLs
like that so far where we had like three
three things at the end of the URL the
most we've been able to deal with us -
so that's why I had to mess with the
router to try to get this to work
but you can see since I did that our
style sheets are coming through and our
logos are coming through
so basically everything we're trying to
bring in from that static folder is not
working so at least we're at a point
where we know a lot about the problem
right so that's a good good starting
point so let me go over and show you in
the code what's happening so we'll be
focusing mostly on on this area here
just to make some more space let's get
rid of that sidebar we'll shrink this up
as well and so this is what I've I've
done I've taken this universal route and
let me know if this is too small and you
can't you can't see what's going on
also hey everyone I forgot to say hi
everybody's saying hi in the end the
chat so so say hello then it just says
sup Jesse Pinkman that's a reference to
Breaking Bad if you've never seen the
show that's why I was definitely not in
the show but there is a character named
Jesse so I took this Universal route
which right now just grabs the type and
the ID so in our example here you know
the typing the ID would be academics and
then ug but then what happens with this
majors over here so what I did was I
copied and pasted this entire thing and
I put in type sub type and ID so now
we're getting all three parts of that
URL and then I went in and I change did
I change
I'll know what I changed it back I I did
change some things in here and then I
realized that I didn't have to change
that much so I undid it so basically I
copy and pasted that and then now what
happens is when I go to see what page I
was trying to get to
oh that when they when it picks up that
the type is academics it tries to send
the data to the page component which is
what we wanted and I'm still only
sending the type in the ID so I just
completely skip this sub type here which
for this use case works going forward we
may run into a situation where that no
longer works and we'll have to figure
out something better but for right now
this works and it just goes through and
it does exactly what this other one had
done which is simply past the type and
the ID into the component from the
component we make a call using Apollo
and graph QL to WordPress which we have
the WP graph QL plug-in installed there
and then WordPress sends the data back
through the WP graph QL plug-in and then
react can render the page and then that
page gets sent to the browser to the
users browser so all that's still
working the problem is somewhere along
the line and we can see it here in in
the terminal hopefully it's still up
here so what's happening is Wow okay
there's so much stuff let's see if we
can get it okay so we we have this is a
good example so anytime we're getting a
static file it reads it a static image
in an ID because our our routes here in
our file so we have the static file and
then image everything within our static
files is two levels deep so that gives
us a URL with those three parts so I I
guess what's happening is it's it's
trying to take those and treat them as
you know our usual route so I have an
idea and let's see if we can if this
will work if this idea works then this
is gonna be like a very special stream
that that my idea for the fix actually
works so what I'm gonna try to do is
just wrap everything in
and if stamen so let's say if type so
this will be rec params type equals
static whoops is sorry is not equal and
I'm silly because I already have that if
statement right here alright so there we
go so nikki is actually the one that
created a lot of this so I've done very
minimal editing to his original routing
function and I forgot it in so he had
already come across some of these issues
before and put in this as statement so
because there were some other things
that are doing this so now we're just
going to add that at if statement and
say if the type is equals static we're
not gonna go through this let's see if
it doesn't mean let's see if it works
oh you know what
Nikki's apology apologizing for the
spaghetti nassif the code don't even
worry about it this is this code is
awesome
this definitely did what it was supposed
to do and you know we've just come
across some extra use cases that we
didn't even realize at first so we're
just gonna have to keep adding on to it
I think to handle this
AHA yes okay cool so that worked now I'm
going to try to go to another page and
see if it broke our other pages so first
the home page excellent home page seems
to be working and now let's go to I
think this works yeah this works
excellent
excellent okay very cool all right cool
so that part of the routing works now
I'm sure this can be reflected somehow
because we have a lot that we're just
reproducing here so I don't know that
I'm gonna be refactoring this right now
during the stream but just just so you
know I wouldn't I really would rather
not leave it like this that adds quite a
bit of length but for now this is
working so before I had to do this what
I was working on was trying to edit our
object here that allows us to put in a
lot of different routes and get some
more of these pages working so if you
weren't if you haven't joined us for
some of the previous streams you might
not know what we're trying to do here
but we're taking an old site and we're
completely redoing it so the entire back
end the database content management
system front end everything totally
redone but what we need to do is try to
keep the URLs the same because we've
this site's been around for a long time
it's built up a lot of links some you
know external links pointing back to the
site so we need to keep those intact and
in fact one of the things that the the
vice-president of admissions here at the
University asked about and he was very
positive about the site but one of the
things he asked about was is this gonna
break any of the links so he was very
pleased to hear that we're doing
everything we can to make sure it
doesn't break the links but that's
definitely a concern and that's a
legitimate concern you know there's a
lot of materials that have links to
different parts of the site so emails
that go out and printed brochures and
things like that
those
and all be changes because we got a new
site you know it can't be changed right
away that costs a lot of money and takes
time and you can't exactly recall what's
already out there if it's already been
given to people okay so let's go to the
last thing I was working on and this was
this this academics link so here's what
I was let me just walk you through the
last few steps I did so we're all on the
same page and I just realized my Spotify
has not been going for I think since I
started my playlist just ended and all
right let's put on something those
alright I'm gonna let you decide what
I'm gonna listen to so I have some old
school 90s rap I have some like dubstep
and I have some old school 90s rock
music put in the live chat right now
what you think I should listen to
90s rap 90s rock or dubstep and I'll
check back in the live chat just a
couple of seconds whoa looks like rock
rock rock rock rock alright cool that
this seems pretty all we do have a
dubstep we have alright so we have some
other things in there but it looks like
90s rock definitely one James s if 90s
rap includes Tupac it does it most
certainly includes Tupac but I think
Rock one out so I'm starting it up now
and looks like this is one of those
playlists as Spotify just makes for you
so it looks like I have Pearl Jam
sublime REM Nirvana Red Hot Chili
Peppers looks like a decent playlist so
far cool
all right so here's what I was doing I
was tryin to get this route for the
majors so it's been a long time since we
even checked looked at the routing but
basically to get to a page that displays
information about a particular major for
like a prospective student who wants to
check out our what we offer here you
just type in the URL so in this case
would be localhost / and then like
economics or accounting or whatever
major we have which is a little bit
weird that it's not we it would make
more sense if it was like local o slash
major slash whatever it is so it made it
a little bit difficult so what needs to
happen is we need to add routes for
every single one of these so for some
reason I could not get these routes to
work and I worked on it for longer than
I want to admit this morning and realize
that I simply did not have any piece of
content that had the slug of economics
that I could grab from WordPress that
was probably my problem all along and
what I had which is basically this
probably works right away it would have
worked so anyway so that's what I was
going through here but then I also have
a page to display all the majors
unfortunately when I brought the data
over that was in an entirely different
category so it's it's like under
academics so that's what got me onto
this academic section and
eventually got me onto whatever that
page was that we were just on so let me
go back there we go
academics undergraduate majors so now
[Applause]
that's why I even had to mess with this
page I don't like this URL but for now
like we have to keep it active so what I
should be able to do now since I have
well let's go to economics since I know
that data is correct I should be able to
good economics from here and the link
was supposed to work
cannot query field economics pages it
shouldn't be clearing the field
economics pages it should be majors
unless it's case sensitive I don't know
why it would be but I guess we could try
it it might be case sensitive no it's
not
yep I think it's case-sensitive all
right so we're gonna have to fix that
you know in our routing so it seems like
some of the links that we've just
brought over from the old database have
capital letters in them and all of our
lengths here we're checking for
lowercase so let's find I want to try to
figure out where we can do this so we
only have to do it once or maybe twice
so let's take it out referenced
[Music]
maybe I'll just make another let's make
another like a variable here I think
that'll be the best
oh you know what I can't I can't just
set type here
so what I wanted to do is said let type
equals no type
let me let me check the live chat
quickly here
let's see Nicki says at the end where
the options object is construction
constructed you can lowercase there
thank you awesome
I knew there had to be there had to be
something type so we can go to lowercase
to lowercase and I'll also need to do it
down here since I now have double and
there the ID
you know what maybe we ought to do it
for the idea as well I don't I haven't
come across the case would that be an
issue but doesn't take long to put in
another to lower case alright so I'm
gonna save that and then we're going to
give it another try
what is the difference here
well this is silly
and I shouldn't have to manually restart
the server but maybe I'll try so let me
hit save see Ikki says that an entire
object can go and be inlined into
rendering cache by the way that's for
when it gets refactored okay cool Thank
You Nikki all right
so I'm just shutting down the server
bringing it back up scene if we have
now that's that's silly
okay
so I'm just I'm gonna do this just to
test it out and make sure that I'm
actually worrying about the right thing
so I'm gonna make economics like this so
we'll also have the uppercase version
and it should work if that's really the
issue okay yeah that is the issue so it
seems like our to lowercase down there
is too late
okay I'm gonna check my timer all right
about two minutes so about two minutes
I'm gonna go back to the live chat so if
you put any questions in there just hang
on for a few more minutes and and I'll
get to those okay so you know down here
when I'm changing it to lowercase that's
that's too early because it's trying to
look things up in this translation
object here and it's trying to look up
economics with a capital e and it
doesn't exist so we need to move that to
lowercase up higher
this seems like something this really
seems like something that later on could
be done at the level of nginx which
we're going to use as our reverse proxy
on the server I'm assuming that we could
do something in nginx that would take
everything in the URL and make it
lowercase before it even gets to this
point but I would like this to be
functional for the demos coming up the
more the site that is functional the
better it will seem to the people I'm
presenting it to so we can think of
something it doesn't have to be a
spectacular solution because ultimately
it'll probably be temporary until we get
this on a real server so that's what
we'll do when I come back from this
break so let me go back over here have
about 15 seconds left so I'm just going
to start this break right now and go
over to the live chat and I'm gonna
start way up at the top so if you asked
the question just a minute or two ago I
may not get to it in this five minutes
but I'll do my best
all right so have a question from I'm
gonna have to use Google Translate on
this because this is not in my normal
alphabet so let me get Google Translate
going on my other screen bow Don so bow
Don asks can I incorporate view will
react in one of my simple HTML pages
with further upload to basic hosting
without changing the web hosting plan I
think you can I think there's a way to
use react I I don't know very much at
all about view so I really can't answer
that but in terms of react I think
there's a way that you can bring in
react to your project just like with a
script tag I've never done it though but
I kind of remember when I was going
through like the tutorial phase of react
like the beginner tutorials that there
was a way you could do it so if anybody
has any experience with that
please let bowdoin know and if I yeah I
can't remember exactly I suppose the the
official react documentation would
probably have something in there about
it so I would check their IB Shaykh says
was that the one you're going for in the
last coding session I assume you're
talking about the interview thing yeah
yeah so I think the last time that I
talked to you all in a live livestream I
was talking about going on that
interview hmm sorry yeah so that was the
that was the interview so I'm not gonna
say a lot about it in the stream because
I just did that video so if anybody I'm
sure a lot of people in the stream don't
care how the interview went so I'm gonna
save
and then if you do care check out the
video and you can ask me any questions
you want about it as well I'm you know
I'll answer those michael says congrats
on the interviews
thanks thanks I appreciate it Alexi says
Wow everything is looking really nice
yeah the site is actually looking you
know pretty nice up maybe I'll go
through and just kind of scroll through
some of the stuff that that's working I
can't remember how much I had done the
last time we strained I know I had done
some things like before a presentation
it gotta make it look nicer and I'm not
sure if I showed you all that let's see
buh-buh-buh John Shay I'm sorry if I'm
mispronouncing your name let me know I'm
supposed to pronounce it but it says why
so much hard-coded stuff in in the
router or lots hard-coded we're really
it's because I have to keep these routes
from the old site and so far this is the
best way that that I've been able to
come up with that we you know it's not
just me we've other people who've been
helping out with it especially Aniki but
it's kind of the best way we've come up
with to try to keep those routes so we
can't really use the default routing
system that comes with next jazz because
we need to try to keep these routes
working from the old site and if you're
referring to some of the other interior
pages why the charge code is stuff for
right now things are hard-coded just
because I needed to get them in for
presentations but at some point there'll
be very very little hard-coded and
nearly all the data will be pulled from
from elsewhere
I John Hanson says have you heard of
github probably marked down to JSX
bring over the marked up data from
WordPress you can override markup to a
consistent style and I believe it won't
be dangerously set innerhtml okay
interesting all right well maybe want to
check that out
I'm not yeah right now I'm not worried
about using dangerously dangerously set
enter HTML because I'm pretty much aware
of what's what's in the data but yeah at
some point that might not be a bad idea
to get away from it sorry I'm yawning so
much
I wasn't feeling well yesterday and I
think I'm still not a hundred percent I
just kind of sluggish and tired I didn't
have any coffee this morning
I I'm gonna mark down where I'm at in
the live chat and the timers up so I'm
gonna have I'm gonna go back to coding
numb and then I'll come right back to
where I left off and get through the
rest of the questions but I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell you just I'm gonna take a
couple seconds here and tell you why I
didn't get coffee this morning and I'm
gonna sound like one of the laziest
people I'm sure but in the morning
usually I drop off my kids at school
around like 8 a.m. so I did that this
morning if I'm being honest though it
was like 10 after a day there I was a
little late this morning but so I
dropped them off about 10 minutes after
8 a.m. and then I have to drive by a
McDonald's to get to where I work and I
downloaded this new McDonald's
where you can just put your order in the
app and then sit in the parking lot and
somebody will bring it right out to you
right which is which is really cool
especially like the weather has been
really cold lately so it's nice to not
have to go walk through like a slushy
icy parking lot you know in my dress
shoes right uh-huh and I know I could
just go through the drive-thru but this
is even better I can just sit there
right
and I just saying this that sounds super
lazy but anyway the app wasn't working
today
so instead of just going through the
drive-thru like a normal person
I thought well you know forget this I'm
not going I can't use the app and just
sit in my car
I'm not going so I didn't so I didn't go
I didn't get any coffee this morning
it's like so I all day I've been wanting
coffee and I just haven't had coffee
because I'm I was too lazy to actually
just sit in my car and drive through a
drive-thru anyway I sound so terrible
know that I said that out loud but if
you haven't used that a bit if the app
is actually pretty nice it takes all the
pressure off like when you go through
the drive-thru it's like you don't want
to take too long for your order because
people are waiting in the same way if
you're in the store like you're in a
line and but if you're just sitting in
the parking lot on your app like you can
take all the time in the world to figure
out what you really want I check on my
coupons against anyway enough about
McDonald but the coffee's not too bad
and it's pretty cheap so that's why I
just stop there sometimes all right so
we all right this is where we're at we
need to fix this right so the idea is I
just got a little noise in my headphone
so we see so Steve I got a message from
work okay I don't think so I think it
was just Twitter okay
Michael Chris's firstworldproblems yeah
most definitely a first world problem I
just
the more I told you about that the more
I just felt like dude like I'm so
terrible that I'm even complaining about
this this this this is not a real issue
okay let me get rid of this thing on the
side just give us some more space okay
so we need to do then is add our to
lower case higher up so I guess we can
remove it from here so let me just kind
of hit undo a bunch of times
oops there we go
all right so we're gonna get rid of our
to lower case there Oh what's up all
right is this
it's Ju Li oh is it Julio or Julie oh
let me know
I want to pronounce it right server set
k sensitive routing true or case
sensitive routing false awesome
okay so app dot set case sensitive
routing false so cool
so you're saying I can just do should I
do
yeah apt outset or server right now I
think probably sir if that's for Express
I'm calling Express to the server so
let's try it this way first
oops server dot sets okay whoops
close
see if that doesn't Rubin says looks
like you have a scar on your face did
you slay a dragon yeah I don't know if
you could see of like right there is the
scar no unfortunately I didn't do
anything quite as cool was that although
I mean if the dragon was pretty chill I
don't know if I really want to slay it
but my daughter Cordelia who's one
thinks it's hilarious to just like slap
you and scratch people right so that's
that's what she did so she was just
being so sweet sitting on my lap and all
of a sudden she's just like BAM and and
got me like all down here and then she
just smiled laughed cuz I guess that
makes sense to a one-year-old actually
you know what here's what I'm thinking
though the case-sensitive routing might
not this still might not solve our if
our issue like I mean assuming I did
this right and didn't mess something up
I still don't think it'll solve our
issue because the problem isn't really
with the router the problem is in how
we're you know we're calling this this
object and trying to look up and match
things so what we really need to do is
make sure that whatever gets passed into
this object is lowercase so I don't know
that this would would switch everything
to lowercase or not if it is and I'm
mistaken please let me know but
otherwise I think we we ought to
manually set yeah we need to manually
set this
all right I'm gonna try something that
right now to me seems really silly like
there's no way it would work but we'll
see so let's go and type equals
I'll try it out hahaha it did work Wow
okay
I can't sometimes stuff that's just like
us there's no way this will work this
just seems too easy here's the thing I
want to make sure that this will still
this will still work so I guess we're
always gonna have a tight though aren't
we yeah yeah we'll always have a tight
should we do the same thing with ID I
guess but maybe we should say let's
let's make this conditional so
whoops
so if this exists then we're gonna make
it this otherwise it's gonna be null and
we'll do the same thing here okay does
this make sense so I want to check first
because I'm not sure if I would get an
error on this but if I try to do to
lowercase or something that doesn't
exist I'm assuming that that's not then
it's not even let me do that
oops what's going on here
it doesn't like it without it it needs a
space there okay and then I can take
this and copy it down into our other one
down here and yeah so that would work
all right Nikki says that that
definitely will cause errors so it's
good to have the check Michael said that
that second one so I did catch that one
in the second one so I had typed here
and I shouldn't have
all right Nikki says type is required so
the check should pass always fast in
that case that's what I thought
that it wouldn't even come through here
unless there was a type but I'll leave
it in there now
let's see I don't think you need that
before
equals
what if it's so we have some some
questions your says ah mrs. what if it's
not a string it's I don't know I mean it
should be a string so it's coming
through the the URL I mean can we put
anything in a URL I mean yeah
technically I could just put numbers in
but wouldn't it still come through as a
string if it's in a URL I don't know I
mean I was just assuming that anything
coming through a URL would be a string
and ducks she not sure I pronounced that
let me know how you'd like it pronounced
says I think you don't need that before
equals and and null I'm not exactly sure
what you're saying I don't know why I'm
not I may be I'm just missing something
so if you can clarify a little bit I'd
appreciate it okay so I'm not sure about
this whether or not this is doing
anything for now should we I don't know
if we should leave it or just get rid of
it let me think if there's a case if all
our routing is coming through yeah I
think we'll probably be fine without it
but we can put it back in if we we need
to later on
I wonder what the default is for Express
if the default is is case sensitive or
not case sensitive okay here we are and
I would like to check out a page that
uses both type and ID just to make sure
we haven't broken anything so let's go
to let's go to our student profile this
should use as student profiles yep yep
this still works okay cool
all right since we have that I did say
I'd scroll through this quickly so you
all could see what we have so some
changes that you may have seen depending
on when the last stream you watched was
we've gotten rid of all the social media
icons up top and our our button up here
it's a lot more clean we have you know
just four menu items and our our search
we've gone to a larger version of the
logo that actually says the word
Franciscan instead of just F us we still
using the F us in this menu and on
mobile
we've changed up some of the names of
the menu items so not not really a big
deal but some of them are changed we've
added in this xsf us was up here in the
button and now it's here
I think we've added a few other things
and change the name of some things and
then on here I did change the buttons so
the buttons are now this is I I call
them inverted buttons I'm not exactly
sure where I got that from I'm I
probably got it from somewhere I'm not
claiming I made that term up but I've
been using it for so long that I can't
remember I got it from so anyway these
are nice because they show more of the
background which is kind of cool I think
I'd still like to mess with the fonts
and things probably needs a bigger font
we've added in a little section to
explain a bit
more about the university about it in
this kind of banner section as well and
then I've just taken some of these these
student profile cards and instead of
using them just for student profiles
we've used them for other types of
information and that's about it and
everything on mobile of course is still
you know very much the same I think it
actually looks nicer on a phone than on
a desktop at this point which is I mean
that's how we've been designing it
okay let me see all right cool we've got
about nine minutes left here all right
so I was I believe I was showing yeah I
was showing this page and then it didn't
work because we had gone - yeah so I was
showing the majors page and then
clicking the links and majors and
realized that that didn't work if the
URL was capitalized so that's how we got
to here but it was I'm actually really
glad that we found that bug better to
find it now than you know for someone
else to find it in one of my
presentations it would have been the end
of the world you know I I definitely let
people know it's still work in progress
but still it's good to good to make the
mistake live here in front of all of you
on YouTube than to make the mistake in
front of 12 people in a conference room
on campus right I'm not sure that that's
actually better one way or the other
all right well actually I just got some
feedback on this so let's go over this
feedback while we work here and that way
you all can contribute here let's see oh
Michael did say even though you already
did the interview I'm still going to
work on the seating manager I've almost
got the lube for requested seats for
missing something okay cool
Michael that's awesome actually for the
react version of it I opened up a bunch
of issues for stuff that I'd like to do
that didn't have time to do so I don't
know I keep going back and forth on
whether I should keep working on it and
I'm trying to think of some like useful
thing like if it could fulfill a purpose
that you know people need this then I
think it'd be cool to you know finish it
and they
get available to people let's see
Michael crew any of Michael was
referring to the project that I had to
turn in before my interview so if you
want to check that out check out my my
github account and it's a CD manager so
I have nodes seating manager which is
the command line version of it and then
I react seating manager which is the web
app version so you check those out and
you know just do whatever you want with
them
they're definitely available for you to
take the code or contribute or do
whatever you want they're just kind of
fun projects now so Michael says I
didn't notice Evangelization I'm
starting like faith and life better yeah
this was I I usually don't have much of
a say and in decisions like this my only
thing is please keep them short because
it's easier to work with shorter menu
items so yeah I don't know if it's going
to stay evangelization or not I kind of
hope it isn't I did ask in in the
meeting where this was decided I said
you know is there another word that's
shorter than this that we could use so
we'll see how it goes yeah I'm with you
I'm just not sure I have to be honest
with you I think a lot of rethinking of
what's actually in these menus needs to
happen and I'm not really the person
that's gonna be doing that it's gonna be
my boss most likely so I kind of hope
that happens but right now I I can't
really do much about it
and Nikki says maybe make the apply
button not see-through and the other two
inverted the button hierarchy primary
versus secondary okay that's interesting
so we could have apply so I would kind
of look like this so apply would hmm I'm
have to think about that and look at
that what do you all think does it does
it look like to at a place to have two
different button styles right next
each other or does that make sense and
it definitely makes a ply stand out
compared to the other ones yeah I'm not
sure about it
I definitely if the goal is to make
apply stand out it definitely achieves
that goal I'm just I don't know
ix the more I look at it and more I kind
of like it alright to think more about
that okay cool well let's go all right
at about four more minutes
Sean saying maybe the logo colors for
the button colors yeah we did have the
buttons were colored they weren't the
logo colors so they were are the this
yellow color that's also in our color
palette something we definitely could go
with colors this is the kind of thing
that I actually think this would be
great for a be testing so once we do
launch try out different variations of
these buttons and see which one gets the
best response like the most clicks I
think yeah I think I'd like to do that
so whatever whatever you end up going
with for presentations and for launches
I guess it won't matter that much
because I think it would be worthwhile
to test out different variations on our
audience so it looks like don't make
them transparent maybe a light green
background
yeah maybe we can mess with different
different colors I've got to be careful
here though because now that we're
talking about different colors and
transparencies and things I could spend
a lot of time on this alright so I'm
gonna make a decision here and just say
I like these ideas but I think these are
good ideas to implement after we launch
and to test them so that way we'll have
data if somebody comes back somebody I
work with comes back and says what do
you do to the buttons they look terrible
I can at least say we're testing them
and you know based on this data these
buttons give us the best response I
think that'll be that'll be easier in
terms of like right now trying to
explain why we do buttons one color the
other is just going to be pretty much
based on why I think this looks good and
that's really kind of a hard argument to
win against other people too but if we
have data to back it up then you know
you can't really argue against that if I
say hey we're getting twice the amount
of clicks on these buttons and you
probably can even if someone thinks the
buttons ugly if we're getting more
clicks we get more clicks
let's see Michael sit no don't do that
looking on mobile change the border
color and font colors let's see yeah
actually let's check this out on mobile
to mobile I think is where you really
get the benefit of these buttons because
the buttons cover up way more of the
image on mobile so an inverted button
actually is nicer or a you know button
with a transparent background Roland
says the one filled in is more readable
yeah it definitely is more readable I am
gonna increase the font size
I wanted to increase the font size
before but when I did it through these
out of alignment and I had a hard time
getting them aligned and so I just quit
messing with it because I had to go to a
presentation and I never got back to it
let's see Sean says are the harmony says
the font color blends in with the lab
coat yeah you're right you're right it
does blend in with the lab coat I did
put you know the I kind of dark in this
image a bit to try to you know combat
that but you're right it's not it's not
really I mean this image will likely not
always be the image in the background so
I shouldn't worry too much about it but
yeah we do want people to be able to
read it now on a phone it's it's harder
to tell but like on a desktop you hover
over it and then it's it's readable so
it's not as much of an issue on a
desktop but you don't have that same
hover effect that wonderful I guess you
can click but at that point it's like
why would you click if you can't
Sean says yeah true my final thought was
maybe a white apply button in the bottom
buttons green and then on hover invert
well seems like we have way more options
than I even thought of so yeah so I
think I'm just gonna make sure that I
save your comments and then that way I
can refer back to them whenever we start
doing our testing Michael says didn't we
do this last week we were coming up with
a bunch of redesign ideas an hour before
presentation yep yeah that's true I
remember that now yeah some of it was
really helpful though and I did actually
say in the meeting like oh yeah you know
the people on YouTube told me to do this
so I didn't take credit for it act my
the head of my department actually
really liked how clean this looked and I
know it was you all that suggested
taking out all of those social media
icons so during the meeting I took them
out during the meeting and and everybody
really liked it okay so my timer is up
and let me commit this good it's we're
gonna add and then I'm gonna do a yarn
CM right and that's gonna give us let's
make this a bit bigger I don't know if
Onis it bug fix let's do a new whoops
did I yeah feature so let's say
and roster three parameters
alright that that's good no okay
all right cool so I'm gonna make I want
to make sure that that gets up so that
you all can check out what we've just
done and I've you know what I tell you
the truth I see that Michael says it was
a bug fix the lower case I didn't
remember about the the lower case thing
and so after I started typing the
message so you are right that would have
been better categorized as either just a
completely a bug fix or part of it not
in part of it but since it was all in
the same file we couldn't really
couldn't really check it out
oh yeah nikki says and the static
checking the route Wow
it's I should have split everything that
we did up into three commits because we
did do three like very different things
even though it was all based on routing
so that would have made it much easier
to categorize it and pick a good commit
message so I'll have to remember to do
that next time to maybe do smaller
chunks it was alright so now everything
is available in the repository the link
is in the description so y'all can check
that out if you want you can contribute
if you want comment on what we did or
you can take the code and use it in your
own project if you like it's all you
know an open source freely available to
use let's say ok so now I'm gonna go
through and answer all the remaining
questions so if you have any questions
please put them in the chat right now
ok and I'm good to go I have in about 50
minutes I have a meeting so I don't
think there's enough questions that
it'll take up 50 more minutes but just
to let you all know
definitely can't go longer than 15
minutes all right so I'm going to scroll
up a bit and keep going where we left
off the last time Aleksey says this is
still the Franciscan site looks almost
done yeah it is still the Franciscan
site and it looks pretty good at this
point the thing that so the big things
that aren't done right now are all the
data is not migrated over and then even
the stuff that is migrated over isn't
linked up properly so that you can
actually get to it from the website so
I'm going to be focusing most of my time
when I'm not streaming on moving data
over and getting that router full of all
the routes that we need also Harshit set
up for us a file I are actually I really
want to show this to you all and because
it's it's kind of an important thing we
have now that will let our client-side
routing work where's my data is it in
here I thought it was in there let me
shut some of these menu
all right here it is so we have this as
URL now so not only do we have a link
URL but we're also kind of manually
passing in some of these things that go
into the router so you could see like
the the type so we have the page what is
going to so basically like what template
component do we want to render this data
so in this case we want the page
component the type meaning the like the
graph QL type that we're requesting it's
academics pages and then the ID is
majors right so that's how we get client
side routing to work otherwise I think
we are still getting a page refresh when
we were clicking that's not what we want
so it we should be able to get server
side rendered pages on the first load
but then after that we shouldn't have
another page refresh so in order to make
that happen we now have this extra thing
so in any of our links we need to add
this so for now like we're pulling in
data but if we were to manually add a
link somewhere like hard-coded and you
know we'd have to add this you know it's
kind of extra information in so that was
pretty good work I didn't even notice
what was happening Harsha noticed I
believe it was hard to notice it and
came up with the fix for that so that
was pretty awesome I assume Harshad is
sleeping right now he should be is it's
pretty late in in the Himalayas right
now but anyway our should if you end up
seeing this at some point thank you for
that but as you can see I don't I don't
have it all filled out so I'm gonna have
to do that as well
Rufus's URL end points aren't dynamic
I'm not 100% sure would what you're
asking so I let me answer what I think
you're asking please let me know if it's
not a good answer to your question but
the URL endpoints so essentially some of
them are and some of them aren't right
so like these are going to have to be
like there's going to be some like this
where you know we're actually hard
coding in these routes but then there's
also going to be some more like let's
see
so like HR these human resource pages we
have a bunch of pages that are going to
be HR slash and then something and
that's where the ID comes into play so
as long as we have content that matches
up with that ID in our WordPress
database it can render out thousands of
pages that would be like /hr slash you
know whatever you want at the end so
it's kind of a mix of some hard coded
routes and some routes that are I've
been calling them parameterised so
that's that's kind of where we're at
right now and I think I mentioned
earlier the reason for that is because
we have to keep URLs the same as we've
had them before so if we were able to
just build the site from scratch and
have our own URL structure we wouldn't
need all of this stuff unfortunately we
we do have to keep the URL structure so
we're gonna have kind of a big messy
object here and a lot of stuff down here
as well but the result is going to be
well worth it right we don't want to
lose out and have broken links and lose
out on SEO and all that so I mean that
takes years and years to build up so if
we have to spend a few extra hours
keeping that it's definitely worth it
netskope says I know this is web
development but do you have any ideas
for a c-sharp project I could do I'm
almost one semester ahead of my class
and completed my extra projects I got to
Wow
I'd say truth I don't I don't know I
don't have ideas for anything that would
be like c-sharp but specifically good
for c-sharp what do you all think what's
a good c-sharp related project I mean I
just kind of know there are always basic
ones that people do like do a to-do list
or a calculator or you know but those
are all kind of boring and really basic
rubenesque do you work out a lot I've
been working out every day for like five
or six weeks now I kind of lost count
but pretty much every day one day I just
kind of did some stretching because I
didn't really have a lot of time but
other than that I've been working out
every day this morning I did not work
out I was tired and my three all just
wanted to cuddle so I just counted with
him and but I do plan on working out
when I get home
to keep my street going oh I've been
working out I make sure I do a little
bit of cardio like at least a half an
hour and then I have been doing some
weights and things like that so this is
all kind of new for me though before
that it was very much like I worked out
sporadically you know I'd do a couple
days here and there and then I might go
like two weeks without doing anything so
I'm trying I'm trying really hard to do
that mostly for my mental health really
I mean it's nice to you know be a little
bit stronger but
it's it helps me with with depression to
get that workout in so in addition to
medication and counseling you know the
workouts a big thing as well so I've
been trying to keep my sleep schedule
you know on target eating a little bit
more regularly and better and then also
with with the exercise so so far it's
it's pretty good tell you truth lately
I've it's like I don't know I haven't
been I've been a little bit more down
than usual lately I'm not sure why but
for the most part over the last month or
so I've felt really good
okay we have some questions about there
was a question a long time ago about
react and putting it in a regular HTML
project so we'll have some follow-up to
that so where do you put react other
than a script tag that is don't you just
source react start Jess I think it
depends it depends on how you're
bringing in react so like on a project
like this you know we are bringing in
react here we're importing it right into
the components but we've used create
react app on a regular HTML project I
suppose you could you could use the CDN
like as was mentioned in the live chat
as well so I suppose you would just use
the script tag and link to the CDN that
would be the easiest way to do it
BBJ says hello all the way from Nepal
hey how's it going thanks for watching
Michael says by the way don't use that
camera angle for the recap again the
gray hairs in your beard really stand
out yeah I am
so he's referring to the video that I
just put on my my chin my youtube
channel that was the interview recap so
yeah I that was the first time I tried
to do a video with my phone so my phone
camera is even the front-facing camera
is much better resolution than the one
on my iMac so I decided to just do that
so I literally like just took my I've
like a standing desk thing where my
keyboard can go up so I put it up to
like right here and I put my phone here
and so that was the angle that I ended
up getting so it wasn't ideal I just was
like hey I would rather have like a
1080p quality video so I mean when I
record with OBS I can scale up to 1080p
but it doesn't look like 1080p because
the camera
can't capture that so anyway I will take
that in consideration and yeah my beard
is getting some gray headers in it I
look a lot younger I think when I shaved
my beard maybe I don't know maybe it
does have something to do with gray
hairs of course but yeah I'm like maybe
a few gray hairs like down here in my
beard my wife thinks it's funny
suheib SS UHA Y B not sure how to
pronounce that very sorry if I mess it
up let me know how you'd like me to
pronounce it but anyway they say I am 13
and I'm watching these videos awesome
that's that's really awesome if you're
already taking you know coding that
seriously that you're watching YouTube
videos on it and especially these videos
because I know they can my videos can
drag on a bit and be a little bit
difficult to watch you know but just
they're long and sometimes it can be
boring especially for working on stuff
and it's just not working so anyway I
think it's awesome that you're you know
watching these videos and learning about
coding so feel free to ask any questions
I'll do my best to answer and keep at it
Aniki says I know what I'm gonna be
focused on while watching that video not
yeah so everybody go and check out the
gray hair in my beard and you know it'll
get me more views so it's it's fine if I
gotta use my gray beard here to get
views then so be it
I'm scrolling down and find more
questions
I'm scrolling through all the discussion
about the button colors
Kemal says which visual studio code
theme are you using the theme is called
SETI so SETI
it's the SETI theme so it's the same
theme that I used when when I'm coding
an atom so I've been using this theme
for years it was one of the first things
I tried out and I just I really liked it
and so I've never switched
oh I see that Niki already gave the
answer thanks for that Niki Jonah says
you got any experience deploying to a
sure it doesn't work for me with no js'
apps I've never tried to deploy an
odious app to Azure so I have deployed
something no you know what I did deploy
note but it was part of like a workshop
so I took like steps that were already
plotted out for me to do it so I've
never tried on my own but I'm it's it's
possible I know I'm you know we did it
I like so my only experience with it was
in a workshop so I'd have to go back and
look through all the steps again and
that may or may not work in every use
case but um I mean it's possible sorry I
don't have enough experience that I
could give you more you know advice on
on that
kukuku so CH you KW you let me know if
that's not how you pronounce it
coo coo says do you know a school
available for me I don't I don't know it
depends it depends on where like where
you're at how much you you have you know
time and money you have to be able to
dedicate to the school I mean there are
some good online you know tutorials and
programs available that you could do
from anywhere as long as you have an
internet connection you know well free
code camp is free you could go through
and do that it's not exactly a school
Udacity has some grade like nano degree
courses my wife is just finishing up
with she actually just finished this
weekend Flatiron school she really liked
it so I guess those are theirs so my
options if you're looking more like a
normal school like a university or
something like that then that that
probably depends a lot more on on
location and you know how much money you
have and you know what you want to do
with it as well
[Music]
I'm mission says how is the react part
being sent and used I you know what I'm
not sure what I was talking about when
you asked that question so I'm mission
if you could clarify a little bit I'd be
happy to answer for you Joey says I have
an idea for the hero do feel free to
ignore if you at a time background color
with background blood blend mode soft
light let me see let me see if I could
if I can try that out let me see where I
have that hero components there's my
components there we go
all right let's see
all right there we go so let's see
you know what I may have to I don't know
if this will work like this Joey so the
dev tools much more readable
okay so Joey just did it in dev tools
so Joey was that for the entire curative
or just for the buttons okay it works
with the background image all right
let's check this up then so yeah let me
try it in dev tools as well that's that
would be much easier
that definitely is we're readable what
do you all think about that
Ali says 23 and watching from Turkey
lots of thanks for free code camp are
you welcome thanks thanks for saying it
thanks for watching now michael says the
stuff that doesn't work is the best part
of your videos we all get to yell out
solutions cool Michael says I'm out I
got to figure out the loop issue and
then work on my Simon game that I
haven't worked on for three months to
get the front end cert all right well
good luck with that Michael John says
are you ready to learn webassembly
coming to a react environment before one
can say
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious webOS
yeah I need to learn some webassembly
stuff I keep hearing so much about it
all the time all of us says I would give
the apply button more top space yeah it
does it could definitely use a little
bit more space
it doesn't look as bad on mobile though
but you're right I think you definitely
could use I think this whole thing could
use some redoing of space and font sizes
I think it's just a little out of
balance
Aniki says good idea in in that UI
details Twitter thread as well d
saturated photo plus bold color plus
blend mode multiplied great for hero
banners and creating high contrast for
text Joey says the image gets slightly
brighter if you take the gradient out -
okay cool John says I don't think CSS
image blend mode works across a lot of
browsers at this point or we can check
it out with with browser testing as well
so I'm gonna keep this in mind actually
I want to kind of let go yeah it's so
much more like the text stands out so
much yeah I'm gonna bring this up I'm
gonna show this baby to my boss and see
what he thinks this is the type of
change that I can't just make I think
I'm definitely gonna because enough
people have seen this hero image and
stuff and really liked it so I can't
really just slide this change in here
but I really like what it's done for the
for the readability here
and John yet we're gonna have to do some
browser testing at some point maybe we
could have like a nice fall back as well
I'm mission says what I meant before
about react was if all your react
components were being sent in the public
folder do I have this already I don't
think I have this compiled or anything
oh yeah I do have a look forward
now I'm not sure I'm not sure what all
ends up being in the public folder once
we build it to be honest with you Joey
says it could be done in [ __ ] or
Photoshop to avoid compatibility issues
yeah you're right
I I'd rather not I'd rather do it in the
code if possible because that way if if
we have people who don't know how to use
Photoshop or [ __ ] try to upload an image
because eventually I think this image
you'll be able to change the image just
by uploading a new image somewhere so
maybe WordPress maybe somewhere else and
the image would change I think it'd be
better if we kind of automatically get
this this effect but love to test it out
and yeah it's at first I need to see if
this is acceptable and we can even do
this and then we can worry about you
know browser compatibility and things
like that but I am I have a meeting in a
like a half an hour and my boss will be
in the meeting so maybe I'll just bring
my laptop and show show him then all
right well I've gotten to the bottom of
the live chat so I think now's a great
time there in the stream he gave me just
a few minutes it's a relaxed before my
meeting and get everything ready it was
it was really cool talking with you all
again I miss you oh I miss I miss
streaming and we we actually worked out
a lot of stuff so I'm really happy with
what with what we've accomplished as far
as getting the router working and got a
lot of feedback on on this this area of
the UI as well which is always welcome
because this is the first thing people
see you know this could determine
whether or not they stay on the site
whether they click they scroll down you
know so
I've said before I think spending the
most time on this area and on this page
is definitely worth it right so I I
think I'll be back tomorrow I haven't
checked my calendar for tomorrow yet so
I figure though I should be able to get
in at least an hour of streaming I'll
let everybody know on if you follow me
on Twitter on Instagram or if you follow
this YouTube channel you should get
updates at some point I've been updating
on all those places the notification on
YouTube will come up automatically if
you turn on notifications for this
channel so that you'll know whenever I'm
going to stream and thank you so much
for watching and have a great day